you are part of this iconic picture in
the Situation Room with President Obama
Vice President Biden Hillary Clinton at
the very moment that Navy SEALs
terminate Osama bin Laden yet not much
later or at that time there was the
Syria crisis and Isis in the government
President Obama then decided not to do
anything while at this moment more
people has idea that Isis is even a
greater friend includable to freedom
then then al-qaeda and definitely at the
time that said that banana was
terminated
why what's what happens well it's a long
answer but I'll try to make it I'll try
to make it short first you have to
distinguish between the fight against -
or the Islamic state whatever you want
to call it and the civil war that's now
ripping Syria pardon has been for the
last six years the fight against the
Islamic state is actually going well
based on the strategy that was
implemented conceived and implemented by
the Obama administration and that is
trying to destroy - at its core in Iraq
and Syria to take away the physical
Caliphate that it's tried to declare
which has been a place that then
physically attracts foreign fighters
allows it to exploit resources and then
in a less literal sense figuratively
gives it a story a narrative that's very
attractive we're on the verge of taking
away that self-declared caliphate in
Mosul and also in Raqqa in Syria and
then you still have to deal with its
manifestations in different parts of the
world the fact that it inspires
individuals but I think we're on a
positive course in terms of dealing with
that problem the same cannot be said for
the civil war in Syria and of course the
two are connected because as long as
Assad remains in power and in power and
as long as Syria remains torn apart it
will be a place where there's a vacuum
and it will be a place that attracts
extremity
you to some extent to fuel - the anyone
who had any responsibility for for our
policy myself included with regard to
Syria has to accept the reality that we
did not succeed and that on our watch
many many many people suffered and
that's something that we'll have to
contend with for those of us who are
involved for the rest of our lives I
think there's a plenty of blame to go
around starting with the Syrians of
themselves starting with Iran and Russia
and the other patrons of the regime
starting with all of the Arab states and
other neighboring states but we have a
responsibility to as a country that more
than any other in the world has some
ability to mobilize the international
community to deal with these problems I
think there are lots of reasons that one
could give for why we have to date not
been successful
certainly the overhang of the Iraq war
weighed heavily in a desire not to have
American forces bogged down in a country
hundreds of thousands for years at a
time the difficult intervention in Libya
which succeeded in getting rid of
Qaddafi but did not succeed in avoiding
a vacuum after Qaddafi the departure
that's actually proved to be
unfortunately a place for extremists and
terrorists to go to that two ways on but
the bottom line is that when you look at
the history of civil wars they tend to
end in one of three ways first one side
wins but in the case of Syria that's not
happened because whenever one side has
gotten the advantage the patrons from
the outside of the other side have come
in and supported it and it's rebalanced
things to some extent second the parties
fight to exhaustion but at least
according to historical studies that
takes ten years on average when they're
just two parties involved and many more
years when there are multiplicity of
parties involved Syria is just entering
its seventh year so that suggests that
exhaustion may not be around the corner
the third way is some kind of outside
intervention some combination of
military political diplomatic
intervention that's what we've been
trying to do trying to get everyone on
the same page among the outside patrons
to try to bring this to an end by using
their influence with actors inside of
Syria but the interests are so dispersed
and so different among
different actors inside and outside of
Syria that that's proved to be a very
challenging process that's where we are
it is not satisfying in the least to the
contrary it's usually frustrating and
it's something that weighs on anyone who
had any responsibility for Syria I hope
that the Trump administration can now
use its best efforts to try to continue
this process and bring the the civil war
to an end